いっ
ハーイ奴奴奴奴奴安スターズえええっええっ
矢部22歳だった熱いんだよ上はこんな暑い中お前達は何を食べるか俺は知ってる
アイスクリームだ
そう熱い表やはりアイスクリームが食べたいんだろうにゃんだけどもう勉強拡大さ
こちらですガリガリ空相談しまーこちらのダリ風相談があるんだけどもう巻いたりし
てんの通りなんだけどアイスクリームじゃないピクチャすぐ食べちゃってペロペロて
ちゃってするため者
かない時は1分足らずでもアイスクリームを食べちゃうっていうそのアイスの美味しい
至福の時間というのはたった年度市葛梅ちょっと短い児童を倒すとでもコーンさん
ドラセナ取らずや衣服 sh 件全2種って降っても花仕事だと思ってをた指定する
こと二度とラブホ spv さあもっと長い時間を楽しめるようで恋バナリナージュの
科学者にもっとコンスタンティン広がってく大丈夫かここを走ってその秘密を持ってる
わけないけどもうそれだけで育ち
やっぱ評価したスープじゃなくなっちゃってそうな顔しないかもと女明治館楽しいこと
にばガール解い重ねぶっちゃけ何て言ってるおねいる僕がやりたいのはアイスクリーム
パンアイスクリームつーかな
付ければお宝すぐ壁ちゃんとても短いんですけどまぁこれは拠点歳で機能と考えた
もっとながら会津国も長い時間楽しめるために高
ません今日はこちらの誰が陸送男子をあれだ
1滴ずつね食べていこうと思います外でベランダある目外で1滴ずつ食べていくんです
けどこんな普通に食べると短時間で食べ終わるアイスク
でもどれだけどれだけ長い時間楽しめるかっていうのはねちょっと絶対に検証して
みようと思いますイグッここにコーヒもうね上から潰してここにガリガリ君を置くぞに
今も作る
こんな感じですこんな感じでここにガリガリ君を含みたりガリ君をここでおきます
ロスターとしている
12時を斬れぬ風邪
梅はおらんで
おります
ええええええ時計時計とけ
[音楽]
ん
んし
結果は4位
おおーー
あっはっは
あがいるんですね
あこれだっ
[音楽]
さあカズカズ kazu 月
もうな generous の方だと思うんですけども少なくなればなるほど出てくる
スピードが遅さってなくなるんですよね
バーンタイ終了です
ちゃんと全部なくなりましたああいうわけで今回の実験でわかったところですねあり
狩り君を1滴ずつがもうとすると外だとで暑い日の外だぞ25分かからぬということが
分かりました是非ところ暇な人と金時間がある人ぜひよっ
てみたら良いと思います僕は二度とやりませんばいちゃ
[音楽]
ん
ます
しています